TURNAROUND AFTER LAST-MINUTE
HURDLES GOT IN THE WAY OF A
DEAL.
>> GRIM FACES AMONG WORLD POWERS
AS NUCLEAR TALKS HIT A SNAG.
AFTER 18 DAYS OF MARATHON
NEGOTIATION, WORLD POWERS HAD
HOPED TO ANNOUNCE THE DEAL
MONDAY.
SECRETARY KERRY PREDICTED THE
END GAME.
>> I THINK WE'RE GETTING TO
SOME -- --
>> Reporter: EUROPE'S TOP
DIPLOMAT GAVE THE THUMBS UP.
IRAN'S PRESIDENT PRAISED HIS
NEGOTIATORS FOR REACHING THE
PEAK OF VICTORY.
EVEN POSTING A TWEET, SUGGESTING
THE DEAL WAS DONE, BUT HE
SUDDENLY DELETED IT, AND TWEETED
AGAIN, ATTEN AN "IF."
THE FOREIGN MINISTER SIGNALED NO
DEAL.
>> THIS IS A DETAILED 100-PAGE
DOCUMENTS.
THE SEQUENCING AND THE
PARTICULARS OF HOW THE WORK IS
DONE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
WHILE THEY'RE MAKING HISTORY,
THEY DON'T WANT TO MAKE ANY
MISTAKE.
>> Reporter: STILL ON THE
TABLE -- HOW MUCH ACCESS
INSPECTORS WILL HAVE TO IRANIAN
MILITARY BASES, TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT IRAN'S EFFORTS
TO BUILD A BOMB.
HOW MUCH ADVANCED NUCLEAR
RESEARCH IRAN CAN CONTINUE TO DO
WHILE THE DEAL IS IN EFFECT.
IN IRAN'S DEMANDS TO LIFT A U.N.
ARMS EMBARGO, INCLUDING
RESTRICTIONS ON BALLISTIC
MISSILES, TO MOCH RUSSIA AN ARMS
SUPPLIER, BUT WHEN THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF
CALLED A RED LINE.
>> UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD
WE RELIEVE PRESSURE ON IRAN
RELATIVE TO BALLISTIC MISSILE
CAPABILITIES AND ARMS TRAFFIC.
>> Reporter: EVEN AS IRAN
MARCHES TOWARDS A DEAL -- ON THE
STREETS OF TEHRAN, THE CHANCE
WERE "DEATH TO AMERICA AND
ISRAEL.
>> PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU